[Musica]
bella qualcuno vuole un po di estate
ragazzi ho notato che effettivamente
utilizzare le porte che si chiudono ma
che non è male come situazione se poi
puoi neanche ventare devo trovare
qualcuno che magari entra in elettrica
dell'altro c'è qualcuno elettrica si
erano in due che spiega che se non
fossero stati in due
sarebbe stato molto molto più easy
perché il problema è proprio questo il
discorso è che se fosse stato uno solo
avrei ucciso con le porte chiuse
purtroppo non si poteva fare sta cosa ma
se avrebbe funzionato sarebbe stata una
gran roba bindi non ha senso se gli fai
stai facendo qualcosa vero però che gli
stia effettivamente facendo qualcosa 28
cesca ed è stata un'ottima kill
effettivamente morta sento step zitto ci
capita che sono blu sono io lì che noi e
pulita che in aria pulita perché era con
me certo se entra nelle altre che ho
visto tipo dietro lerma di aki ho visto
che stava succedendo qualcosa di sporco
comunque palesemente nord anche se come
dell'inglese immagine la ndrina di
elettrica ricordi che è nata votato non
ignorare esatto attenzione mazzo da
succedere a gavi fidate non so che non
dovete fidarvi ma fidatevi dei denti mi
segue da mezz'ora votate dennis e non è
lei sono io non l identici notate detti
poi michele il fido di dati ok se non è
lei sono io e due ore che tenta di firma
la tripla di stalking questa non è la
difesa
lei non mi sento di fare è un triplo dei
tavoli visto cagando anche addosso
allora ragazzi vi spiego cosa è successo
of camera semplicemente successo che ci
allinea sito messaggio mi fa buttarmi
fuori e io non buttata fuori ho buttato
fuori l'altro impostore perché charlie
me ma che sta facendo questi qua è
proprio questo è il discorso è una cosa
veramente strana perché non ha un senso
perché ci hanno investito perché vuole
crearmi un alibi
questo è quello che effettivamente è
successo vuole voleva farmi un alibi
allora ho detto che facciamoci fammi
fuori cosiddetti non sapranno mai che
sei tu per la prima che ne sono da solo
cacchio sono da solo completamente da
solo ci prova spetta a sì adesso nessuno
fa 2 perché hanno visto che c'è che non
abbiamo vinto perché nessuno può fare
due interne no grazie
no mi sembra palese che sia bardi perché
secondo me raga
sempre fermo non c'è stata mai in a chi
le ha notate ma cosa vuoi da me io sono
d'accordo anche perché ragazze con
chieri marsicana the rock e ricordatevi
che ha riportato io sono fiero che un fa
vj ha riportato stefano sono era da solo
non si è scesi piero che un po vige
tutto il tempo ma mi sono mutato
ovviamente ma che i ragionamenti fanno
io pensavo di vincerla tantissimo perché
non fanno in tempo a fare oggi ce
l'abbiamo stato che noia dai partner ha
vinto stress ha vinto bene la votiamo
step per forza io non sto capendo che
cosa sta succedendo là pazzi era andato
io con che noia è andato io con che noia
sono completamente pazzi di mesoraca
ditemi voi siamo d'accordo che è una
partita trolla dove ognuno di noi
quattro potrebbe aver fatto cose di cosa
assolutamente civile
perfetto quindi calma perché se una
delle quattro mura della casa
l'impostore vince se invece evitiamo di
votare a caso possiamo tranquillamente
vincere la pendolare labbro animarci
basta dare forza e suonate certo sono
chiamate al giorno al tempo in modo tale
che loro non riescano a farlo e poi li
ammazzo arrivando dai sta arrivando
arrivando lo ha capito quando fa ed è di
mamma denti sempre stata vicino a
qualcuno mi sembra sarebbe ucciso
qualcuno
[Musica]
tempo e si chiama fa vj march queste
margini ci scommetto che volete farci
porca va a caso si fa vigenti chiaro o
chiediamo un assist a partita anche se
effettivamente è sicuramente un po vj
koper statistiche è un impostore almeno
un faringe impostore chelsea capi io non
riesco a capire chiesto fa vj qua che
c'è anche mi ha copiato quale mar ci
emarginano aimar ci sono quasi sicuro
che sia marci
porcaccia vacca alla caffetteria e
continua a girare sul corpo un file dei
che corre ma torno sabato è morto
non so quale di due fa vj fosse il resto
agazzi 6 milioni o fai vigendo 6 milioni
vabbè 6.600.000 uguale ragadali verde
anch'io
io mi chiedo dice schede di non mi hanno
ucciso abbiamo ballato un po signora
siamo stati bene insieme
[Risate]
ma che partita è bellissimo
non so più chi sono io io sono questo
qua marrone con la scritta famiglia di
norma no perché le altre ma ci sia
motore portato micron l'avessi segue
rischio in killer
a seguire perfetto è stato bellezza si
capisce chi sono si capisce non capisco
non capisco niente di stockeau qua
allora e allora innanzitutto voglio
sapere dove eravate adesso in consiglio
io avevo paura entrare in electric all
allora era vessicchio di fuori perché è
detto che era in caffetteria era l'unico
che poteva essere delle zone dove ci sta
il cadavere ma mi sa che è passato due
fa vj alla anno cesenate vabbè
chiudiamola li tuteliamo il dubbio
vediamo sera davvero lui ha detto che
l'avevo incontrato prima mamma mia mamma
mia mamma mia
l'altro ed ha di sicuro di sé fa vj
salve ed è piedi e teddy fate le tasche
vessicchio vessicchio di quale city o lo
sappiamo che non sei tu ed è di 3 fa
vige insieme la squadra i disastri oliva
dj ed è di volta la barraca facciamo una
cosa buttata ms il full circle col mio
ma allora cosa mi accusi abbiamo perso
vado incontro alla morte da uomo
grazie stefano devo pagare su paypal ha
macinati sei più scarso della morte
giocatori non sospetti su di te e non
primi achille di nuovo sono sospetti di
attacchi agli altri vai 20 fiore 5
minuti dove la gente dice no a nato e mi
sbagliavo è buono e poi torni a giocare
abbatte dopo due minuti
porca miseria
[Musica]